there are so many brands being built  right now on tick tock that are going to  monetize for next decade while everybody  keeps laughing about the fact that their  daughter spends an hour to make a video  in the kitchen people are grossly  underestimating what's happening this is  a very important time this is the last  decade you're going to have to take  advantage of the current state of this  internet and i think that people need to  get way more serious about it and you  look at the behaviors the decisions at  the top the allocations of dollars  against it and what it's being asked to  do there's very few corporations in the  world that understand what's going on  social media is the slang term for the  current state of the internet so when we  call it social it's hahaha when you call  it the current state of the internet you  have to take a step back and be a little  more thoughtful of it